en plein mois de juillet au centre
national du rugby à marcoussis
l'équipe de france moins de 18 ans est
en pleine préparation pour une tournée
en afrique du sud
au programme trois matchs contre les sud
africains les anglais le pays de galles
parmi les joueurs sélectionnés un jeune
yvelinois léobard et il est un joueur
complet
d'abord il est très athlétique il a une
grandeur qui est intéressante pour
pouvoir lutter sur les balles aériennes
c'est aussi un très bon communicant un
très bon leader pour sa première
sélection les eaux s'est illustré en
inscrivant un essai face à l'afrique du
sud le premier match de la tournée
remporté avec succès 43 19 parlait
français ça représente beaucoup de jeu
pour l'équipe de france
sportivement ça m'a fait progresser au
niveau rugbystique j'ai appris plus le
appliquer ce qu'était le haut niveau et
humainement ça m'a bien fait mûr et
surtout grandi je suis sorti grandi de
cette tournée aujourd'hui les eaux
entame sa troisième année au pôle espoir
de lakanal à sceaux une structure gérée
par la fédération française de rugby
pour former au sport de haut niveau en
plus de ses études
le rugbyman yvelinois s'entraîne plus de
10 heures par semaine ça représente une
étape dans la formation
vingt jeunes de passer par un peu à
l'histoire après on est passé pas une
obligation de passer par un pôle espoir
mais je trouve que c'est sympa ce fait
progresser quand même le joueur crée des
déséquilibres
c'est un joueur déjà qui est
physiquement que des belles qualités
et puis après il est assez complet sur
la technique individuelle avec bonnes
passes bon jeu au pied
ce qui reste à travailler un petit peu
c'est sa capacité à lire les espaces
libres face à des défenses très
pressante et quand on est très près de
la ligne
en fin d'après midi direction le stade
jules ladoumègue à massy pour un
entraînement avec son club sa cinquième
année dans cette équipe
le rugby léobard et l'a dans le sang
grâce à son grand père et son père tous
les deux anciens joueurs du rugby club
de versailles
il commence à l'âge de 6 ans ça fait
trois générations où ça se transmet de
père en fils chez la famille bach et on
est tous demi d'ouverture au demi de
mêlée donc on aime bien analysé la
vitesse la technique on n'aime pas trop
le le contact même s'il faut faut
s'envoyer
aujourd'hui je me sens très toujours
versailles et que massicot enfin j'ai
commencé à verser mon père était
versailles et mes grands-parents
versailles et mon grand-père versailles
et donc vous sentirez toujours
versailles il est repéré rapidement par
un dirigeant de massy lorsqu'il joue en
catégorie moins de 12 ans
cette saison il joue avec l'équipe
crabos du club essonnien avec des
entraînements le mercredi et vendredi
soir je connais les eaux depuis qu'il a
10 ans quand il jouait à versailles
il frappait dans l'oeil de tout le monde
et ne l'a pas mis longtemps à le repérer
là mon objectif principal de cette année
c'est de faire le tronc à destination
avec les moins de 18 ans
et suivant ça je verrai les contacts que
j'ai avec les autres clubs
donc pourquoi pas rester encore quelques
années à massy ou
j'ai ça sera à voir à la fin de l'année
pour l'instant pour l'instant je me base
sur une bonne année à massy une voie
royale pour ce versailles et avec
l'objectif d'intégrer un jour le quinze
de france